so today we got some insight on the
first spider-man far from home trailer
as we know Marvel has three major movies
coming out in the first half of 2019
Captain Marvel Avengers 4 and spider-man
far from home we've already got the
Captain Marvel trailer and we're
supposed to get the Avengers 4 trailer
this month in November and the
spider-man far from home trailer is
supposed to come out next month in
December also I'm still giving away
copies of Infinity Ward Deadpool 2 and
ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray as well
as some special edition posters if you
would like to enter the giveaway for
your chance to win all you have to do is
be a subscriber like the video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero so to be
more specific the first trailer for
spider-man far from home is said to come
out with the release of spider-man into
the spider-verse
on December 14th honestly this makes a
lot of sense release the spider-man
trailer at the premiere of the animated
spider-man movie what's going to be
really interesting is to see what they
show in the trailer they're showing the
trailer for spider-man 5 from home
before Avengers 4 comes out in theaters
and right now spider-man's dust so again
this will be pretty interesting to see
what they show now of course it will
probably just be a teaser trailer and
the Avengers 4 trailer should come out
before this trailer comes out but still
you have to wonder what direction
they're going to take but the fact that
they're releasing it in December is
really good news
spider-man far from home releases right
after Avengers 4 comes out so this means
that everything we've heard about the
Avengers 4 trailer releasing in November
is pretty much true so we've gotten the
Captain Marvel trailer already this
month we should get the trailer for
Avengers 4 and next month on December
14th we should get the trailer for
spider-man far from home so this is
pretty exciting news but let me know
what you all think we're going to see in
the spider-man far from home trailer let
me know your thoughts in the comments
below and don't forget to subscribe
comment and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything related to spider-man far
from home and Avengers 4 as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]